hello I'm busy getting animated about
language and this is why you should join
me we've been digging into the
decipherment of ancient scripts and some
languages out there people sing when
they speak so how does that work it's
the u.s. is 50th the state and one of
the most popular tropical vacation
destinations in the world but how do you
say its name did you know that bees are
out there talking to each other right
mouths storytellers have old knew how to
spin tales with monsters and ghosts like
in Homer's Odyssey spirit possession and
Lady Murasaki's tale of genji or even
spooky settings as Dante's Inferno
ancient Sanskrit turn that dial 1000
years into the future what will future
English be like